not another video please I can't [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] anymore it's been 84 years
please release me from this curse I
don't want to act like a [ __ ] online
anymore okay one more how's it going
Brisbane is gonna pass welcome to muddy
Heights too in this game you poop think
of the most attractive person in the
world I know I'm right in front of you
but the second one most attractive that
person poops now I want you to imagine
that person pooping I realize you're
probably having a seizure right now
don't worry I'm gonna keep playing just
make sure you don't bite your tongue all
right we got a new level we're at the
beach snap we got people on segways
we've got people in pulse
there's babies we can poop on babies and
hot babes okay so we're just sitting in
the lounge having a nice relaxing day
but suddenly we had to take a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yo hit the ring hit the ring yeah
hole-in-one baby oh man what it's so
nice to be a poop I think I'll go to the
beach can we put on the duck
that was a good [ __ ] let's try and hit
the jacuzzi come on come on come on all
the muscle builders cuz you're not
working out right now it really doesn't
even matter exactly there's no specific
exercise it's not work better yeah nice
and steamy why does no one love me I
have one question actually why does the
poo make poop noises just to poop have
its own butthole I am legit curious
about this
hey guys can I dance with you why does
the woman scream like a man not that I
would conform to any gender stereotypes
no really please don't post a tumblr I'm
sorry I just thought if we was wearing a
bikini how could I have known how could
I know well that's the end of my youtube
career I [ __ ] up oh hey DJ [ __ ] yeah
I'm the DJ now mr. DJ Kalia on this mix
part
one of them is actually a piece of [ __ ]
and the other one is as well all right
let's see if we can hit that baby doing
backflips because it's pissing me off
[ __ ] should we do a shitty this is far
to me I think we should do a shitty this
is part of me this is sparta I backed
out last minute I'm sorry I think the
baby is dead I think I killed the baby
let's see if we can make it to the ocean
come on to the ocean baby get the [ __ ]
out of my way lady get away buckets yes
see logging can we make it to the boat
ah yes we made it captain poop are y'all
ready to eat I can't hear you look at
this guy enjoying his day you just got
sunscreen baby now here's the question I
never thought I would ask can poop climb
ladders
ah
sorta the answer is sorta okay Potiphar
come on this is where I belong guys in
the trash let's try higher jump we got
to get all the toilet paper brush come
on
oh man we jump high
yeah give me that toilet paper whoo can
we climb this ladder and I've
underestimated the struggles of being a
piece of [ __ ] I am hiding no one will
find you no one expects a piece of [ __ ]
to hide come on come just oh my god I
have spine puppet from I am to poop
monocles lift Oh
explode with em we're gonna bomb the
[ __ ] out of this pole this pole it's
gonna taste the beauty pipe fury aah
come on baby
we're missing one toilet paper look at
us up there just taking a [ __ ] so classy
where is the last toilet paper it must
be in the hair i side i think i sign
their nests oh my god yes mom mom I'm
coming back I'm coming home mom
all right so kawaii so kawaii poor guy
that guy looks like Cooper went inside
him can we play with the basketball
oh we can amazing I am having the time
of my life
alright that was poop game 2016 muddy
heights check out this game see if you
can beat my high score what is it what
is my high score five thousand and three
hundred and forty six download this game
post a screenshot if you read my high
score
I will send you my [ __ ] sign pewdiepie
thank you both so much for
green-lighting this game I think that's
really cool of you and as always stay
awesome bros hey you look you look good
you want to go on a date I really like
your chest maybe you could squeeze one
out for me too